hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video Rebecca unforunately and this
should be the last video hopefully I
don't have to make another video so I
don't have to blow up your cell box feed
I do apologize for that but today we are
going over the second part of the dead
stream which covers the LOB ringer
rework the Raider rework as well as the
new weapons for the hito kiri or Sakura
as well as the season 10 weapons for the
other characters within the CAF so
everybody's getting a little bit of
something this season so it's always
like the VP do enjoy subscriber for new
I cover the informational side a
foreigner that being the balance changes
the hero updates the patch notes and the
leaks so if you want to be kept up to
date with everything happening within
the world of foreigner definitely stay
subscribe to the channel my Twitter and
discord will be in the description down
below well let's get started with these
three works so as I stated we're gonna
be going over the reworks and first up
was la barrier we're gonna be going into
Raider a little bit later within the
rework section of the video but for
daddy law bringer that got himself the
problem is that his shove on block is
easily dodged and can be countered with
ease especially because it also promotes
a defensive style of play and it kind of
stops the game so they had to make it a
little bit more offensive so we're gonna
get into that in a second and but the
really good thing about him is that he
has really awesome parry punishes and
the legendary bomb bringer build 444 is
super good so they always try to keep
this in mind throughout the rework
so first up to start shovelin block is
now gone it also it stopped because it
was only defensive and it really made it
slower and they want to make the game
more offensive and really in your face
as compensation they gave him a triple
heavy combo and a heavy heavy light
combo with the lights in the game
they're now gonna be 500 milliseconds
except the top lights which are now 400
these side lights are also going to be
uninterruptible so you can continuous
chain attacks even if they are blocked
the goal is so players can get that
unblockable heavy finisher and it can be
achieved a lot more because whenever
there's an unblockable people of course
have to move and have to react to it and
with law burger you really didn't get
that unblockable heavy finisher all that
often so that's really the main reason
why they edited so that's really nice to
see on top of that after every
unblockable heavy finisher you can now
follow up with a quick light for that
extra damage if it does happen to land
in the flip attack and the Train move I
completely forgot all the names with
these but you'll see them on screen now
they can now be stopped like shamans
bite and chew go keys hug so they can't
carry the
guy throughout the entire map and you
can get that extra damage and a team
fight they will be stopped immediately
some good news is that the regular show
from neutral is still there and it
actually guarantees a light attack this
time instead of a gate and you'll
guarantee Myint every so often and now
guarantees a light every single time you
land it and you can combo that light at
seconds the unblockable heavy finisher
he also had some parry changes as well
the light is still guaranteed off a
heavy and the top-heavy unblockable is
still guaranteed off the light attack so
that's all well and good the zone attack
is now unblockable but only after a
parry if you do it from neutral it is
just the standard zone attack so finally
a buff to it and maybe this can be used
into some type of mix-up or maybe a
different type of switch up if you don't
want to use maybe an unblockable heavy
maybe they're really reacting to a
pretty well maybe whip out the zone
attack since now that is unlockable
shoves can now be used after a heavy and
now unblocked miss or hit I believe it
used to be just off of a hit or a block
I do believe or not I don't remember
everything I don't really play too much
longer but now it is after every single
thing so if they block the attack you
hit them or you completely miss it you
can now follow up with the shove after
that and for the damage his light attack
finishers and his heavy finishers have
all been increased roughly by about 5
damage the full details on this patch
note will be available next week so
don't worry you can look at that I'll
definitely try to cover that next week
sadly they don't have it now so I can't
really go into more in depth solely to
apologize but yeah let me know your guys
thoughts on the logger Network
especially you but you'll all bring
remains out there let me know if this is
a viable type of rework if this is gonna
be good this will make him even worse
let me know your thoughts next up is
from our Raider boys he has a couple new
chains a light light heavy a light heavy
heavy and a heavy light light are his
new chains according to the developers
all light attacks are now 500
milliseconds and the second and third
heavy within the chain now have hyper
armor so it can be used for a little bit
of training all of his heavies endzone
attack can actually now be saw fainted
into guardrail line form or mix-ups
potential like that so that's really
nice to see the stunning tap is now 500
milliseconds as opposed to 600
milliseconds making it a little bit
faster and you have a lot more leniency
when it comes to using the stunning tap
as opposed to using it right away you
can delay it a little bit which is nice
so that can even provide for even more
mix ups now he also has a different zone
attack just like log bringer so the zone
attack from new
is now gonna be from the left but during
a combo it comes from the right I do
believe of what they said is correct so
that's gonna be a little bit of a mix-up
there I like that that there's two
different variations kind of like JJ's
own attack which is really nice to see
and don't worry it is still unblockable
stampy charge now has the same
properties as you go keys hug shamans by
Tennille all bringer and pail move to
where it now can be stopped by attack so
make sure to let your Raider hit the
wall first and then you can go into that
damage don't do it while he's doing the
move as for the damage stuff all the
lights are being increased by for damage
the heavies are gonna be increased by
five and I believe the developers did
say that the zone attack is going to be
increased by eight extra damage so I
think that's our own thirty eight damage
which is really nice and all these
static guard Heroes is gonna be getting
a 100 millisecond guard change attack
instead of 300 so basically this means
for every character that has a static
guard so everybody but assassins
whenever you would switch to an attack
you would go from the left guard stands
to the right guard stands and then go
for a move that would cook that would
take you about 300 milliseconds that is
now down to 100 so that you can get the
moves out a little bit quicker it's not
a big change but it is a change
nonetheless and it's of course welcome
to all the static guard heroes and then
to end the video we have the weapon
showcase and as usual we do this in
groups of four in alphabetical order so
let's start with what we have first
first up is our a Musha berserker
Centurion and conquer second we're gonna
be having gladiator Highlander chengxun
and Kent's a following third is lava
ringer Nobu she knew she and Orochi the
fourth group entails PK Raider shaman
and Shaolin weapons with the fifth group
being at shinobi shougo key T on D and
Valkyrie
and then ending it last with vordigan
warlord and warden so yeah those were
the weapons they tried to go for a more
minimalistic realistic type vibe instead
of the flashy goal the weapons we were
getting in the beginning of the year
which I'm totally cool with I like the
minimalistic weapons although personally
to me they really did gladiator hard men
like that weapon sucked in my opinion it
looks exactly like a default one that we
couldn't that he currently already has
in the game so I'm definitely not using
that anymore but as for the other
weapons I do like them I really like
shamans a lot our musha's was pretty
cool ken say and most of the samurai
have this type of look on their weapon
with all these flowers on there which is
really sick to see so yeah while these
aren't exactly huge really impressive
weapons like fantasy looking weapons
like some people enjoy I do prefer the
minimum of the minimalistic weapons so
of course I'm totally cool with these
but we're not done lastly we have hito
kiri or Sakura's weapons now first up
the weapon is called the MAS Akari or
the oh no and and then in the
screenshots I'm gonna be showing they're
gonna be going from a low rank to a high
tier rank in terms of the weapon low
rank mean you're gonna get this at maybe
the start of the game rep 1 rep 2
whereas with high tier you're gonna be
eating these rep 7 rep 8 the high tier
stuff the higher end rep you go the
better the weapon looks and of course
with that there's also even more lower
to the character the more weapons and
the higher you go up a lot of these
weapons have some really impressive
grooves and edges some of them are very
basic weapons and more going into
fantasy the higher you go some have
sharper edges that when some have spikes
with serrated blades some of them also
have pieces of metal missing from inside
the middle of the piece which is really
cool and especially the one on the law
in the middle that is white that is
completely different looking from almost
every single weapon in the entire kit
there so that's always nice to see I
like when the weapon is just completely
different like changes the entire aspect
of the whole weapon so I might actually
be using that when I go play heat so
carry on may 2nd I say this all the time
but the art team does a crazy job at
this stuff the weapons on the new
characters look better every single time
we get a new one the handles on the
staff are on this are actually really
nice as well even though if it's a small
change and most of it is really on the
big blade being the main part of the
course there but it is just so
incredible how different these weapons
can look and
the our team does and honestly I cannot
wait to hop into this game get all the
weapons that I can and show this off
because these weapons are badass and
they're but the blades are huge but that
guys is gonna be the end of the vid so
hopefully you guys did enjoy let me know
what you guys thought about the new
weapons
I think heats the heat so carry weapons
are really cool I'm not a big fan of the
season 10 weapons although I did say
before I'm very into the realistic type
personally for me I only play a couple
characters and the weapons that I saw
for those characters aren't really that
great compared to the ones that I have
so these aren't really that great in
terms of my opinion these might be
amazing for you if you kind of fall into
that category as same as me with the
realistic weapons as for the reworks in
my personal opinion I really didn't
think law bringer got that big of a
change I could just be wrong and maybe
this is something monumentally big all I
really noticed is that the zone attack
got a huge change and other than that
shove on block is gone and then the rest
of it was very minor changes so I'm not
really sure how long bringer is going to
move up and down on the tier list I mean
he can't really move down since he's
already been rock bottom they'll
definitely go up within the tier list
within the current meta of the game but
I don't think he'll go up too high but
overall going over the this video in the
past video I think season 10 is gonna be
really cool I'm very excited to hop on
to play some soccer I'll definitely be
streaming the day that it goes live so
keep out for that and yeah let me know
what you guys think about everything
happening with season 10 and as always
let me know what you're most excited
about for season 10
whether that be the weapons the reworks
the new character or any it's something
completely random maybe you just like
the new map or something randomly
changed that you're also into as well so
let me know via like the video if you do
enjoy guys subscriber for new I cover
the informational site a foreigner that
being the balance changes the hero
updates the patch notes and the leaks so
if you want to be kept up to date with
everything happening within the world of
foreigner so that you never miss out on
an update definitely stay subscribed to
the channel my Twitter and discord will
be in the description down below I would
HIGHLY appreciate if you guys did follow
me and join the discord we got a really
huge community up in there hopefully I
believe this should be the last video of
the day if not you'll hear all this [ __ ]
again for the third time today but yeah
my two mostly two videos are gonna be on
screen if you guys don't want to check
that out
now guys take care enjoy the rest of
your day let me know what you guys think
about season 10 and also if you're hyped
for season 10 let me know in the
comments below
love to saw the discussion with you with
that take care and peace out
[Music]